the world needs it let's do it we don't
shift our mindset
nothing changes let's break the internet
again you know let's do it again
and there he is what's up man how are
you
the one and only dean graziosi ladies
and gentlemen oh good man how are you
i'm doing great man good to see you it's
been too long
yeah i mean the last time we did this i
think it was in october november
uh we did the ig live took it to youtube
got a million views broke the internet
uh so
super pumped to have you back on again
let's break the internet again you know
let's do it again man let's do it again
and listen before we get started i
wanted to thank you because i don't know
if i've ever
actually done this publicly but when i
was doing my book built to serve
uh we were meeting puerto rico and you
and brendan brichardt were having this
big event for your mastermind group and
it's a it was a three-day event and i
know so much stress that happens in
launching these things and having to go
and i i mentioned that uh
hey do you guys have any strategies for
my book and you and brendan took
an hour over lunch backstage basically
your only break
you know for the day to sit there and
jam with me on my book and strategies
um and then you gave me a lot of great
connections with the warehouse and all
that to make it happen so
just super appreciative for all the help
and effort dude message to get out to
the world and you're an awesome dude so
i'm glad we could help and i want to say
thank you you're always there for us too
always willing to help and lend a hand
and
my team leans on you when they need
expertise on youtube and all that so
it's how reciprocity works brother i
love it well stay tuned guys dean's
youtube channel is going to be
something special this year i can feel
it in my bones we got to make it happen
uh but topic of the day dean's got this
awesome new program
uh in the five-day own your future
challenge it starts may 11th
he's doing with tony robbins he's doing
it with all of the big names and
personal development people you know
recognize
love uh starting very soon may 11th and
youtube will we'll link that up in the
description below for you to go check
out
just give us the quick high level of
what what the own your future challenge
is all about man
yeah you know listen let's just face the
world is completely shifted right
if you haven't felt uncertainty scared
unsure where the world is going
what you should do if you should pivot
shift discover something new if you
haven't felt that way
you're kind of not human with all these
changes going on so
you know tony and i have been dear
friends for a decade and partners and we
did
a challenge in in january about shifting
your mindset
right i mean this is your world evan and
if you're watching us right now you
either might follow me or evan you know
this is our world if we don't
shift our mindset nothing changes right
we kind of
it's like who moves my cheese you kind
of sit and fold your hands and wait for
someone to wave a magic wand and fix it
and the fact of the matter is no one's
coming to fix it this is this is on us
so january we did a challenge called the
new world new you about mindset we put
830 000 people into the challenge it was
unbelievable
190 countries i mean it was off the
charts i mean
if you ever looked at a picture of a
half a million people that were at
woodstock the
famous concert in the 60s it's it's a
mountain of people and it was more but
now
since then we help people with their
mindset so many people have asked about
impacting their economic future how do
they shift their own economy right how
do we fix the global economy
we shift the economy in our homes but
when the world changes
you know tony said this and i love it
it's like humpty dumpty broke it's not
going back together the same way
and if it's not going to be the same
world when it opens back up how do we
have the capabilities
to know where the puck is going wayne
gretzky right
from canada but that's it i love his
when
he was asked why he's so good he said
most people go skate where the puck is
i figured out how to skate where the
puck is going and when it comes to your
economic
future building your own economy you
need to know where the puck is going
so tony and i got together and said
let's do another challenge about
building your own economy let's
pull back the curtain for five days and
show people an industry that's
exponentially growing an industry that
everybody can be a part of
an industry that the world needs now
more than ever in industry you and i are
both in
evan and and tony but now everybody can
be in this industry we can be connected
this way and that's the knowledge
industry the
self-education industry everybody has a
message a mess they've gone through on
the
they're on the other side they have a
story there they have a hobby a passion
that someone else
right this minute wants and needs it'll
pay for so
we said let's let's show people how to
enter or scale in this industry and then
we started thinking about it and then
we asked jenna kutcher and brennan
bouchard and prince ea
and and just we kept asking all our
friends and shailene johnson and
glowatonmo and
all these amazing people and they kept
saying oh my god the world needs it
let's do it the world needs it let's do
it
i mean if you if you see the the
speakers that are that are coming
you won't believe it you won't believe
the speakers and here i'm going to share
every one of them is doing it for free
and and these are people that get
anywhere from
50 to 300 grand for 60 minutes 90
minutes on stage but
it's unprecedented times and people need
unprecedented
opportunities capabilities and who
better than tony in this group to
inspire you to know it's time to get off
your hands
time to forget the old cheese and go
find new cheese so
anyway that's what we're doing it's may
11th through the 15th it's the own your
future challenge it's live
it's gonna be two o'clock eastern
standard time probably two
two hours a day uh no replay so you're
gonna wanna i don't know if you have a
link in your bio i have a link for you
but you
you can tell people if you've got a link
in your bio or however you want them to
go
but you need to go um seriously if you
never thought about this industry you
need to go
if you're in this industry you need to
go if you just need to be inspired and
see what's possible
even when the world's chaotic you need
to go
for youtube check out the first line in
the description below
and we'll pop the link to get in there a
million people is what you're expecting
dude this
it's crazy numbers yeah it's crazy well
you know i mean listen
you got to dream big right like here's
the thing so
we did 870 30 000 people and we're going
for a million because listen
just say it like it is we've had the
chance to spend a lot of time together
evan and you know if we just like the
world is in a weird freaking place
i mean it is a scary time everybody's
waiting for someone else to
solve a problem fix race issues fix the
global economy
fix communications fix and bond people
together
here's the thing and tony and i have
these deep conversations two nights ago
we spent three hours on the phone
this conversation there is no win no one
coming to wave a magic wand
no one our politicians can't agree in
our country
here in america and we can't agree
around the world the only people that
are going to fix this is us
it is completely on us so how do we do
it we try to get a million people to
lock arms
right to embrace each other and join a
challenge
join a movement gain capabilities if we
could change the economy in our homes
we can leverage we can change the global
conversation we can fix
so many things when we're thriving right
that silly analogy that i heard
years ago and i always use it is when
you're on an airplane it says you know
put your oxygen mask on first and then
you can help the person you're with
that's how we fix the world let's get
our oxygen masks on
that's why we asked all our dear friends
to be a part of it and let's
if we can get ours secure then we can
help heal and fix the things around us
so that's why we're doing it yes we're
shooting for a million people so um
whether you're watching here
on instagram or you're watching on
youtube grab the link
and not only go register because there's
no replay
and and this sounds like a once in a
lifetime but it really is when the world
opens up there's no way we'll be able to
get all these people at the same time
so not only go register like grab the
link
and send it to a friend or two friends
or ten friends because they're gonna be
upset when they miss it fomo's real on
something like this
one of the things i love about you is
you're always
pushing for the next big thing
and even though you've you've done so
much and won so hard
and made the biggest partnerships in the
world you still
play like it's the bottom of the ninth
inning and you're behind by three runs
and pushing hard i mean it's inspiring i
love it i think it's something that
everybody needs and it's it's impressive
to see someone again who's done so much
still just pushing so hard and i have to
tell you i've always had that i've
always played like i'm 10 points down
and then i get to be friends with tony
for a decade and now we we legitimately
talk
every day of our lives and that guy
plays harder than i do
he i mean tony if he quit today
he owns 73 companies now he he couldn't
spend the money for the rest of his life
he couldn't give it all away it has
nothing to do with income anymore
it's got to do with purpose and and
serving the world
and and helping leave a legacy not his
legacy just a legacy to shift like
he's hell bent on changing people's
lives more than anyone would imagine
you'd think it was kind of a facade
if you really didn't know him so i
already had that happen
and then talking to this guy every night
i mean every night he's like we gotta go
we need to help more people the the last
challenge
i said tony i'm gonna work my i ran the
challenge that's my job
he shows up and we both show up and and
impact i said brother i am no one's ever
done a challenge over 300
000 people that i know we're gonna get
to half a million
and he calls me up and he said if we can
get to a half a million
we can get to 750 000. and he said are
we going to leave 250 000 people that
need us now more than ever with covet
and shifting and all this stuff
they need us brother you hear me they
need us how do we get to 250 and we sat
on the phone for two hours strategizing
and we got to 837 000. so this time i
said dude i don't know if we can get
there again he's like
a million people need a steam come on a
million people
need us it's free it's not kind of free
we asked all our friends to do us a
favor to come
we got to get a million so now i'm hell
bent on getting a million people
i love it so i had tony on the channel
to talk about the the new world new you
challenge and one of the things that
came out of it from talking to people
who went through it
wasn't just the motivation from you and
tony and the people there and the ideas
but also
the connection to each other so i think
a lot of people feel like they're going
through this alone they're stuck at home
they don't have other
ambitious people around them talk to me
about
the community that you've also built
inside of facebook
as well as people who joined the the
actual event so
so people feel like it's not just this
one-off motivation for a couple days but
you build friendships really good point
it would it would be someone like you to
see that
listen we are socially distanced that
that is the new phrase of the last
year plus right we can be virtually
connected like never before
and i think that's what is one of the
biggest byproducts of what we've been
creating we have
we have communities online right now if
you go to uh ownitchallenge.com
or you go to the link below not only
will you have the opportunity to go to
this event you'll enter a community
where people are on fire where they're
supporting each other where they're
giving each other love where
everybody's connecting from every
country every race every background
every desire
failure success people doing amazing
people struggling and everybody's
bonding
and really isn't that what we need to
lift people up we have enough bad news
we have enough separation it's time we
we connect and align because we have way
more in common
than we have on the other side of that
and um and i think that's what we get to
do here and
you know until the world opens up and
goes back to maybe close to the way it
was i think this is what gets us there
is there a favorite story from the last
challenge that has that comes to mind i
mean so many people impacted
obviously but is there a favorite story
of yours that came out of the last
challenge that
you can share with us yeah you know not
one in general because there's so many i
mean literally there's
tens and tens of thousands of live
videos in there and supporting each
other
but the biggest story i get is watching
people post
and someone say i'm going through a
really tough time i'm going through a
divorce and then there's
500 comments of people supporting and
somebody on their last
stage of getting through cancer and and
you watch this whole community attack
and support or
i'm having trouble i feel like i'm an
imposter and my husband loves me but he
doesn't feel like this
is for me and and people attack in a
good way like
a lot of people are used to being
attacked today's world for something
this is being attacked and and being
supported
it's almost like an attack of support in
every way possible so
i would say the biggest thing that i've
seen out of is people helping people and
kind of a culture of progress people
taking uncomfortable action
it's pretty amazing i feel blessed to be
a part of it
one of the things i think both you and
tony are just fantastic at is helping
people break out of their own patterns
just the things that we just keep going
on autopilot and
repeating the same story and one of one
of my favorite videos from your youtube
channel
was where you shared a story of how
you're usually not away from your family
for more than three days but there was
one trip especially that you did seven
days just because of back-to-backs and
everything and
you know you're so excited to come home
and then for whatever reason there's
there was some frustration and
and you yelled at your kids i swore at
them or something and then and then went
to
apologize and say hey that's not me
that's kind of my dad's story kind of
coming through me and
you know one just shows you humanity
that hey dean's not perfect either and
he
still you know is freaking stuffed out
but two just
the power of that old story that we all
have
so for people who are trying to own
their own future which is the whole
point of this challenge we feel like
they can't nobody in their family's ever
done it before nobody around them has
done it before
someone like me can't do it how do how
do they break free
of that pattern to actually step into
their new future
the first answer is who did it for me
better than anyone was tony robbins 25
years ago he shifted my
stories and my beliefs when i bought his
course invested in his course off
infomercial two and a half decades ago
and that's what he's working on day one
day one of the challenge just so you
know the master is going to be
busting those old beliefs and and
there's nobody better but the fact of
the matter is what does it for me
because they still
come back in i appreciate you sharing
that and and watching
my videos especially ones i share from
my heart but i mean
literally once a month i will parent
my children in a way that my father
parented me and i love my dad he's a
great dude still alive
but he parented her way through anger
and frustration and
you know his dad his dad beat him
senselessly my dad never hit me but it
came out as rage
and about once a month or once every
three months my son
especially my son he'll do something
where i'm frustrated where it's a great
teaching moment and i'll freaking like
snap and that old version of me or that
version that i knew will come out
and i've caught it through the years and
i've stopped it or i'll stop and
apologize
but i'd love to i mean i'm being
completely transparent it's not a great
parenting moment and i'm mad at myself
every time i raise my voice or
handle it in a way that it shouldn't
have been he's the kid i'm the adult i'm
supposed to have that responsibility
but think about it evan i've been in
this
industry the self-education personal
development industry
for 25 years i'm a multiple new york
times bestselling author
on personal development i talked to tony
robbins
every day of my life i'm best friends
with brendan and all the people we are
we talk
every day and still my
my old stories my old beliefs still pop
out of my mouth and into my brain
after decades of trying to squash it
it's not that what i've realized and
it's the same with all of them
it's never going to go away it's the
ability to identify it and know that
story if it's in charge
i'll replicate being a dad just like my
dad if i use the story that only
wealthy people make money or i don't
have time or i didn't go to college and
i'm an impostor
that's what my mom and dad both went
through and thank god i retired both of
them by the time i was 30.
they never made more than 25 30 000 a
year their entire life
they had stories those stories were
embedded in me
and i've been able to overcome those
stories shift those stories to the point
where when they pop in my head
i can say if i continue to let that
story be in charge
i will have the same results as my
parents or people with that story
and at the end of my life when i face
god or whatever you believe your maker
is
i can say yeah i could have had a
fulfilled life i could have went for it
but i played small because i let this
crappy story that my grandfather gave my
father and my father gave me
and i gave to my kids and this is the
the generations of a story of resistance
in our own bigger future so i look at
those stories like the enemy
um and i identify them and then i go
you're gonna let that story run your
life or you're gonna you're gonna bust
it
so it's really not that they'll go away
it's being the observer of the lies that
our brains can tell us that we're fed to
us at a time in history
identifying the lie reverse it and use
it as power
well and dude that's what i love about
your content whether it's the youtube
channel the podcast or even
instagram you guys don't follow dean yet
on instagram you can check him out
because there's always
there's always some story and it's and
it's almost always sharing
a vulnerability or where you didn't live
up to who you want to be and taking us
inside and teaching us the lesson as
opposed to
i'm perfect come learn from me and i'll
teach you everything um and so i think
it's refreshing i think it's awesome
um and you know i'm a fan so i just
wanted to share that um
what's something that you've changed
since the past
challenge that you learned because i
mean you broke the internet
with so many people at the last one what
what
has changed what's different between
then and what you're going to be doing
in may
yeah um the difference is the last one
was all on mindset
this is really yes tony's going to shift
beliefs but the four days after day one
is about shifting and belief because if
you're not the right mindset
doesn't matter what we teach you or what
anybody teaches you fall back to old
habits
we all know that so tony and i will be
anchoring in day one
what's possible shifting your thoughts
busting old beliefs
and then for four days we're literally
going deep on how do you unlock the
asset that lives in your brain
right this is like real teaching this
isn't rah-rah like we're going to show
you a process to unlock
what you should be teaching who you
should be teaching it to
how you can ethically sell it by serving
not by selling
how do you deliver it with confidence
through our storyteach tool model
and then how to wrap it all together so
at the end of the challenge it's not the
end it's actually the beginning of a new
future for you
where you could pivot so um the
difference is tony took
them through a journey on shifting your
mindset this is a journey on shifting
how you make
you know your career your income your
impact on the world
for people who are signing up want to
get the most out of it it's it's five
days
every day for five days there's no
replay do we
isolate ourselves in our rooms we put
something on the door to say don't come
in do we like what what what advice
because people may not be used to
learning from home in this kind of
environment where if they're coming to
your events or tony's events it's
you know it's all immersive how do we
set ourselves up for the best experience
possible
you know what i've been saying this a
lot and you'll appreciate this more than
anyone evan and i mean it
here's how i'm going to tell you that
you're going to get the most out of this
pretend you paid 5 000
for it like legit go to the link below
register send it to a friend put it in
your phone but then
literally pretend you paid five grand
because at the end of the day
sometimes when you don't pay you don't
pay attention it's like ah tony and dean
and all these great people are doing it
maybe i'll see it maybe i won't
but if you cut a check for five thousand
bucks you'd be there with pen in hand
with your journal you would lock the
door you're in you would close all the
tabs on your computer
you would shut the ringer off on your
phone you would be completely immersed
i know because i've had events where
people paid 100 to be there they took
they wrote every one of my words word
for word as i was speaking
and i let one friend in and he was kind
of on his phone texting i'm like
are you freaking kidding me you're the
person next to you paid a hundred grand
you paid nothing it's it's literally
like it's true so
how do you get the most out of this
pretend you paid a ton of money because
in any other
reality to get tony and brendan and
shayleen johnson
and jenna and prince ca and and trent
shelton and all
you could pay 5 twenty thousand dollars
for an event like this so
i'd say trick yourself that you paid
money and uh
you'll get all the value you need i love
it i know our time is wrapping up
just quick final message if somebody's
on the fence
they feel like they want to they love
the idea of crafting your own future but
they're not sure that they can do it
they're hoping that this event is the
thing that pushes them over the edge but
they're you know they haven't won before
what would your message be to them um
if we keep doing what we used to do
we'll continue to have what we
are currently have listen these are
scary times totally get it
uncertain times how do you get through
uncertain times you gain capabilities
from people who've already been there
i've already been through multiple
markets so is tony we've
none there's not one person that you're
going to be learning from that was born
with privilege that it landed on their
lap they weren't scared
all of them felt like imposters all of
them started for nothing jamie curran
lima worked at denny's
and evolved to sell her company for 1.2
billion dollars she's going to be there
sharing how she did that and how now
she's in the knowledge industry i mean
when do you get the chance to learn from
people like that who were scared to
death
told they're good jamie curran lima told
her face you're the wrong size you're
the wrong shape you don't have the right
look
it's never going to work for you give it
up and go back to what you were doing
yeah 1.2 billion dollars later thank god
she didn't listen to that man
who ended up actually working for her
afterwards which that would suck
um but anyway you get this opportunity
so what i'd say is
it's free come explore but come and play
full out don't don't just come and
dabble
yeah i promise you'll gain capabilities
that'll shift your life
and she she sold it for 1.2 billion cash
too not just
for stocks in the company i love it yeah
it's real money i love it guys go check
it out we'll link it up again
description below dean
thank you for all the work you're doing
man it's just so refreshing to see
the the self-education revolution and
you and tony at the forefront of it and
um
another amazing event i know coming up
and i'm honored to be a small part of it
too
i appreciate you dude we'll chat soon if
you want to see me sit down with tony
robbins to talk about their last
challenge check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe
and i'll see you there the quality of
your life has nothing to do with how
much money you have how many beautiful
children you have how many people love
you
the quality of your life is where you
live emotionally